Rhona happy happy monday first of all a
picture lead a happy happy day I got I
got my extended family in town I'm very
happy and Appa gobble Bryan gobble
gobble gobble these nuts bro gobble
these nuts I'd like to I'd rather have
duck on Thanksgiving I really it's too
greasy for me I don't know what I
brought that Pizza Pizza is a nice fine
pizza yeah
can you what else could you do on
Thanksgiving turkey so lame I know such
as in culture pheasant is delicious have
you ever had pheasant it's simply
delicious what else would be good I
can't believe you never had pheasant
it's the best it's the best bird meat
and the whole huge bird guy I am hold on
I like birds the animal I don't like to
eat them hmm
yes I understand but Birds for me
pheasant is your head hawk impossibly
good overhead huh you don't eat birds of
prey Brennan and that's in the Bible
Bible that's in specifically the Ron yes
and all specifically in the Bible when
we say the bible we mean the estimate
the correct the Old Testament and that's
why why because when you eat animals
that eat other animals can eat out you
can't eat birds of prey Kenny Britt ha
eagles osprey y can eat because when you
eat and when animals eat other animals
typically they carry bad parasites and
what about like we we can eat bear but
you have to grill it like a mother
you've got a brine and give Sherlock out
of it yeah but you notice how people
don't really they'll do shark fin and
that's I've had shark fin soup back in
the day over to China the balls-deep in
charge no these sharks they'll eat
everything
what's there people eat steak yeah snake
is is constantly in Vietnam they drink
the blood of the snake of the Cobra
generally what else can't you eat well
you can't eat typically you weren't
supposed to eat pigs because they carry
trichinosis and a lot of so I'm not a
pork fish yep you couldn't eat
you could eat camel you could eat goat
you could eat
of course you couldn't eat any human
can't eat human you know that rink blood
of that you'd human get [ __ ] up what
you can get crud you can get essentially
what the do you know to cold
well it's called Chris fells disease
it's called laughing disease in the the
Papua you're crazy in Papua New Guinea I
don't know if you know this but there
when when many tribes many tribes in
Papua New Guinea will practice
cannibalism and it used to be they leave
it outside right so you get a nice sort
of simmer on the skin and it turns into
a gel well thank you a couple of things
in the human body becomes basically a
fruitcake well stay eat well if I may
true story yes this is from Jared
Diamond who spent a lot of time in Papua
New Guinea who wrote the great book
comes germs and steel he said you asked
for it I said what he said well they put
their relatives now first of all in
Papua New Guinea some of the tribes
would capture kill and then eat you they
would cook you and eat you moves an old
green and thereo let me see this ring
that is a document yeah now there they
are now here's the other thing
some of them would take their relatives
after they died they put them on slats
and they left us the the relative gel in
the Sun and you drip in the buckets and
then they take their sweet potatoes and
they dip that into the buckets and eat
them because out are insane yeah and
then they get what's called essentially
mad cow disease for humans kreutzfeld I
think it's called kruetzfeldt disease or
something like that either way that's
what happens when a culture is isolated
for 40 thousand years and never shares
ideas with other cultures but you think
when they go get smarter it's like we
should I stopped eating everybody huh
now I feel fine
yeah but until you have somebody to tell
you that you don't think that figured
out after all this time well now they
are you human beings figure things out
when they share ideas with other human
beings it's hard for human beings people
that isn't there well everyone's sick of
[ __ ] you think math a bad idea but I
shouldn't be dipping our [ __ ] French
bread into the humanists there's no
there's no correlation because you don't
know what is kuru there's no there's no
way to really sense what Curie that's
just your theory doesn't exist that's
just the big man upstairs going don't
eat each other beauty children get
[ __ ] up do not eat each other when I
was when I
18:19 i went to the the the back back
area of indonesia where we were studying
orangutans and i went to a place where
there were a lot of people who had not
had a lot of contact with anybody but
sort of themselves it was very isolated
tribe and they were washing dishes in
this mud puddle who guys all dressed the
same they were what they were wearing
the shaman will rain literally this is
these were the dye acts they were
wearing almost nothing and I drank their
rice wine they were all sharing the same
rice when I got drunk on that a little
hallucinogenic but but and I danced all
night with them and I'm not kidding my
lady of the night they were cleaning her
dishes in a mud puddle and I said how
don't they know that's dirty and the
woman said you can you see a germ you
were taught germ theory they weren't
taught germ theory I never forgot that I
was like [ __ ] that makes sense unless
you're sure did you go full dropping
knowledge on for day I was a little
young to do one gather around I was
alluding to and I was trying to have sex
with the 30 year old scientist and she
show but she knew what was up she knows
a lot scientists from the village cuz
you give me like I don't know if you've
heard from the mainland but if you suck
a white dudes dead you live forever well
I didn't have that kind of game Hakuna
Matata
I didn't have that kind of game but I
did I did chat her up and I was like I
live in DC right now if you ever there
give me a call and my sister the
ultimate [ __ ] block goes well he lives
he lives he goes to college their lives
in an apartment with his two friends and
my dad pays the rent and my dad pays for
everything he doesn't have a job she hit
me that's what my sister would do to me
my dad pays for everything he makes a
call but I think if you cook human meat
well-done
you should be alright but you can't eat
the brain at any point or the sky or the
skeletal tissue the central nervous
system that's why what really [ __ ] you
up that's why with deer even in deer
when you're you know a lot of laws like
in Wisconsin you cannot you have to kind
of leave the brain and the spinal cord
intact you're not allowed to ya not
anything you're out to remove it I think
you have to actually dispose why it's
that dangerous yes because that's where
cow disease and things like that live
and there prions they're called prions
you can't boil them you can you can boil
them for 5 10 hour forever and they will
not die they'll put holes in your brain
it's really you cannot you cannot boil
them away
you can't disinfect them away there
there's some strange protein complex
called a prion well it's what I'm going
to break down your your freaking
Thanksgiving holiday weekend we're
talking about eating human just to eat
the meat eat the muscle eat that ass
right he's the muscle buddy are you uh
are you a pie guy Brenda you have to be
worried about your diet your weight as
skin but do you uh know my skin is great
so you can't break out and have apple
pie otherwise you get spots I can and I
will
you're gonna do it yeah yeah I can I
will
I've I've got a theory about psoriasis
not just it's not just a gut thing it's
just distressing the stress thing yeah
that's so weird
you know what [ __ ] string is when all
this is going on you're seeing every
doctor known to man
diets on it do don't think you're
stressed out because you're special
you're deal with personal stuff
you meant no it's weird
well I brought that up welcome the
[ __ ] jaw I will say though I will say
that there's a great deal of science and
it's true and it really did help me that
I went on that probiotic protocol in a
very strict diet it did make a huge
leave difference but I'm and however
main thing like I knew put obviously a
lot of listeners didn't know it's gonna
like I know what you're doing personally
and with the special like there's a lot
of stress going on oh it's kind of been
this bad yeah I just wonder though I do
think part of it was physical and part
of it was my dad just cuz I guess you
get older your body changes I could feel
that I agree that I agree that distress
distress I think that it yeah I think so
much happens from stress
honestly oh my god you know what I mean
people died for it I was watching the
Monica Lewinsky files last night it was
on Amy I never before heard
conversation three in my Lewinsky and uh
the dog her best friend and [ __ ] pill
Clint all that stuff and they were
showing when he was young and I was a
goddamn what a good when was a good
looking little dime piece hippie long
beard but then they but then when
they show him like when he's going
through the thick of things when he's
like with the white gate and all that
stuff
yeah it just white water himself yeah it
just [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean his face yes
because you turn into this just stress
ball yep it just aged like a
[ __ ]
yep like have you ever seen in that's
the thing about Bill Clinton all his
side pieces were terrible but she's have
you ever seen the that they've done over
the last few years with presidents - how
they aged in four years I mean it's
insane is insane
that's all thing yeah it's all stress
yeah absolutely you would not want that
job Presidents before and after stress
didn't have heart surgery she years
later [ __ ] Bush might look bad Obama
was a smoker you know
yeah bomb smoke some cigarettes there's
a conspiracy theory about Obama that he
will used to be a woman and that's why
his Jesus is his ring finger I think
it's longer than it's nothing like
that's that's scientifically proven what
a weird conspiracy theory I get a kick
out of that stuff he's gay he's a woman
and I'm a Shia used to be a man you know
Clinton now looks [ __ ] rugged you
seen Bill Clinton have cancer no no he
had a sari issue he had an artist yeah I
didn't know that Ben Stiller had cancer
what yeah he did and I think he's over
it he had prostate cancer yeah that's -
you know what I didn't either I didn't
hear about Jenna went away and then life
kicking the Dyckman well Paul's seeing
hand of time old father time father time
comes and gets us all unless you're
agent Lee KitKat I know like a day over
40 now I've been fighting it but thank
you for catch me why that's a good thing
cat you just like young yeah I want to
you know have a rink on you come on it
looks like jailbait for as long as I can
yeah you look good Jim for 40 can't tell
man chin looks great white guys white
guys my age the worst huh um also
especially more that's right your hair
gets gray American white guys my age the
worse I think if you sail in the Sun too
long and you're white yeah but if you're
somewhere where it's colder I think you
age better like but well say it to
Russians like black guys age great can
never tell the agents amazing white
girls
why do white girls what girls age rough
yeah
white dudes can use genetics yeah yeah
like girls like girls yeah for sure I
can never tell hold some white girls
like you ain't lyin chin no you good as
you get older people flatter you more
because they feel bad for you oh you
look good
I didn't ask so well I mean when I'm in
the makeup chair and and I'm like I
don't need to use too much makeup on you
have great skin well I don't could
[ __ ] yeah I'll get it done lady come
on man
excuse doing you don't say nothing I'd
feel better if you say nothing
exactly I feel clean like in rugged
though I was interesting in these monica
lewinsky files though because they're
saying he never he never hooked up with
her in overall Oval Office he always did
to the side he liked to room to the side
and it's funny in that cuz I was telling
chin I'm below the belt it's funny
because she was like you know it's very
one-sided relationship like I'd have to
wait around for his call is always on
his time I'm no sure [ __ ] it's the
President of the United so so such end
what does she have Narcy how arrogant
can you get yeah and turn no she's
shaken you know the president can't [ __ ]
me running around the White House with
your dumb ass it's got such a gall very
talking she's like I was a twenty year
old you took advantage of me I'm like
hold up I'm watching I'm getting pissed
like you cuz list of this so he would
come around he'd meet with everyone you
know and she had this nice dress on and
he just went oh I like the color of your
dress so what did she do the next day
she she didn't know he's gonna come
around she found out she rush home
changed her dress so he would recognize
that one and she's like don't remember
my dress he's like yes and then they're
at a whole like gathering at the White
House her thong sticking out she goes
any other time I'd tuck it in but I knew
he's gonna come around so I left my
thong out and you bet he noticed I'm
like bro but you don't take
responsibility no and she was but he
took advance just I was 20 more
you're older take some responsibility
yeah you Ewing horror in this [ __ ]
relation narrative a sneaking around and
then you get busted now this is what it
looks this is what a narrative that
famous this is the narrative that's out
there a powerful white male took
advantage of his power and you don't
have bear any responsibility and this is
what happens yes it was consensual but
it wasn't because ultimately you had
power over me cuz he used the president
and I think I wanted him she goes I want
him cuz he was untouchable and all this
is all what it is this is all I'll say
this though Monica Lewinsky now yeah she
ain't bad looking young she got way
hotter since she got older yeah I don't
like her I think she's she's opportunist
I think she's a huge opportunity I just
don't like her and I think she's not
taking responsibility I think she's no
she's trying to jump on this me to
movement it's like that's what are you
talking about what was me to movement is
Youkilis you like me too yeah yeah me
too [ __ ] yeah I'm the one that I put
all everything at risk I lost my [ __ ]
job because your dumb ass about that no
she won't but but it's not her the women
are victims that this is the new
narrative that women are the victims men
are the oppressors it's a patriarchy
I'll tell you is a down-ass [ __ ] down
hillary clinton men whoa don't you ride
or die like that she's tough cuz when
all that she would come out she was like
listen everyone has issues in the
relationship we're dealing with it
you're telling me the rest of Americans
will have real [ __ ] problems and just
Kapton she's ambitious next [ __ ] side
beast blah blah beat a [ __ ]
beat it [ __ ] she will stay path she's
she's ambitious it's about ambition for
her it was always about I think they're
more business partners like they have
[ __ ] in for ever
correct I will guarantee that I'll tell
you what Bill's a handsome dude had the
most busted girls of all time all of
them they were shown him like god damn
bill show a little pride bring out those
girls ah they're terrible
bills girls the one that he had a 12
year race should probably the best she's
a real [ __ ] though is that true yeah
she was
look at these boats curb row that's when
he was hooking up with him
Jennifer flowers flowers is the main
done he was always he was always a guy
in the news for his womanizing and
frankly his criminal behavior toward one
who's the one with big titties read
fiction I I remember this before he
hooked up like no it's like one of his
friends mistress has been nicknamed
click on that and I don't I'm not mad at
him for it
let me see Bill Clinton's [ __ ]
energizer cuz he goes all night long I'm
not mad I'm not mad at him at all is
that no me neither in does it mean you
can't do his job if he's not at all
gorgeous but now she'll be a prey in the
United States because he likes chicks
but literally now in in stuffer in
America and in academia like this is the
new narrative that men are oppressors
and bad and and we use our power and
it's just I mean forget it do it bill
and risk it all risk the biggest job in
the world young women are pegged on
Elizabeth Hurley do you know that I bet
he did that's what they said she came to
the White House I have no who wouldn't
dick her look at her holiday egos loves
Elizabeth Hurley comes on claims click
on that
she's so uh she denies this she's so
hostile she at that time ant out
dazzling the way I'm a devil she's so
hot and yes ma'am
yeah she was a girl up chin what she say
those early comments on claims she had a
fear of President Clinton everyone close
source says it's so true
she price doesn't know I mean you know
whatever the case a year long
relationship sighs Maura and but listen
Mifflin's I would Eenadu listen man shy
I have a friend who had been there with
would bill know someone else with the
heavy thing do Guerlain oh-oh-oh as a
tomcat I've been right now I got her as
my top five five five all-time when she
was in her prime I think she's a hottest
keep scrolling down says she vehemently
denies it and then they slept in
different bedrooms but it says he was
falling in love with her had to get rid
of her
come on Bill Clinton but you don't come
to Billy's mansion and sleeping safe
anybody break his back it's
it's Jenna Elizabeth Hurley back then I
mean I could let's break my back to
heating this a [ __ ] studio man it is
toasty
she was just unsnap mum to death and ate
her heart with a side of chutney hmm
guess she's your fake on the right there
especially on this site what else you
get Jen that's cuz you looked up Bob
cannibal she was just on the news oh
yeah looking good too recent oh yeah she
the Royals on E that's her show is that
it Josh her accent is she's so sexy - so
hot I just think she's amazing and she
is she's legitimately this is the one I
hear good she had called sexy dress to
the I mean look Thanksgiving dinner
yeah how old is she 48 58 40 what 53 53
she's 50 through that picture she's
incredible [ __ ] she's incredible other
time Reef you hate the touch a father
time also refuses his touch is Robin
right Robin right couldn't look better
Robin Wright is you'll stop about dude
uh Robin Wright who Robin Wright is this
she from force on Thrones I mean of all
the Queen
yeah no Quinby house of cards house of
cards yeah rather - yeah there she is
she was married to Sean Penn for many
years oh yes he is painfully beautiful
52 I mean I was just like are you joking
me I couldn't believe it I saw her at
the premiere and I was just like you're
good good gorgeous
she wasn't he's always sure she's always
been beautiful clear my top five like
Elizabeth but she was younger she was
but she gained that young dude yeah he's
a great actor - that's Ben Foster right
he's so good
yeah he's incredible he's incredible
yeah she is a Tom cab ride we're sitting
I thought Robin white with a dude I
think it upset no but whatever I don't
know she's young better what dude what
dude besides me have not as father time
not touched Josh wolf Idris Elba yeah
well yeah seal
seal thank you seal does not age what
black guys what non black guys its
father Tom Cruise Tom Cruise is done
well needles have touched his face
though well his eyes are looking a
little bit like mine there what the eyes
give you know Hubbard touched him yeah
the eyes on Donner man kind of I think
they start to troupe you see he's not
doing the Jack Reacher oh you know you
know he's better-looking than you I
think they made mr. Reeves
know what canoe he's got some Asian in
him he's Samoan I think right or Hawaii
Indonesian I think oh I saw him at
Starbucks and he is a fine look yes yes
he's also not all mall no he's like six
Jamin on his motorcycle you goddamn
snack yeah man yeah he looked good now
he's a good-looking guy if I if if you
woulda came in a car like a Porsche
summer I would talk shop with him
getting more second thought no [ __ ]
about it so my bridesman cool bike man
yeah no he's a he's a striking man he's
always been a very good looking guy I
would yeah he is crazy rich too oh yeah
doesn't make a bad movie does not make a
bad movie really name one name one name
[ __ ] one you haters in this room hey
maybe one I'm trying to and Ted let me
think man [ __ ] y'all maybe matrix mm-hmm
not Ted's wick what Ted quick what's
what's it John no almost John Swift was
there and Ted quick John wick John [ __ ]
man John where John wick amazing John
wick was good speed speed dope dope
matrix it's classy
one and two dope here's another movie
coming out a new more turbulent ocean
movie oh I saw Bohemian Rhapsody and
scale 1-10 10 great Bravo
really Lavo really [ __ ] tan I can't
manage it I can't wait oh let's see
matric John wick knock knocks Siberia
I've never seen can't stain good
destination win gets a little [ __ ]
either Point Break word that's the
movies coming out this year replicas
which
pretty crazy Bram Stoker's Dracula check
please
devil's advocate [ __ ] yeah
boys I'm rolling yeah never saw that I'm
with three man that that's a franchise
people love it huh I love it
you know who loves it it's [ __ ] Rogen
you won't pipe down about John wick John
wick luck really no villain Ted's
Excellent venture that's where I first
met him okay my first expansion the
replacements yeah when he's a scab you
guys know what that means
ball terms for so and you fill it in on
the NFL yeah you know what some of those
movies towards the end they get a little
tough but you know what you know what
I'm saying you're always gonna make some
shitty move he's worth a boatload of
them and he owns up like a motorcycle
company and he's just a dude you know
yeah but doesn't he buy people
motorcycles like all the stuntmen and
stuff on it I don't know on a set he's
supposed to one of the nicest guys ever
fan we catch him in the item just doing
kind stuff to people yeah he's a very
nice person he's also super intellectual
my friend I don't know if she dated him
for oh yes she did date him for a while
and she she was like he's he's like in
the Shakespeare and everything he's
reading all the time he's do really um
you would love the freddie mercury
biopic though it is really can't wait
it's [ __ ] I can't wait so good yeah
it sounds amazing
it sounds amazing shout out to Queen
possibly the best voice of all time huh
I think so I think I think he's my
number one frontman of all time and my
second frontman it's got to be just
because it's dirty now it's Robert Plant
hmm Led Zeppelin I have to give it to
him
nobody was singing like that I mean
Freddie Mercury is it's such a bomb
afraid we're gonna talk about it with
his wife and she's like you know like
you're gay fret he goes I think I'm
bisexual
she was no Freddie you're gay I've done
this forever you're gay
because that breaks my heart and then
even he moved in a big mansion moved her
next door like in a townhouse right
above so he could talk to her every
night but obviously she's gonna move the
[ __ ] on you know
so like he was super lonely call like
flick the light she wouldn't be there
it's heartbreaking back then being real
ice you had to be quiet about it and
then you super woof woofs yeah such a
[ __ ] freak of a talent man
amazing amazing what was all the
platform Led Zeppelin Oh Google Himchan
educate you to umbrella be Indian
women's after plant in the eighties and
even the most famous song be what do you
think I mean Kashmir I mean black dog I
mean everything stairway to heaven
Stuart heavens huge but you know you
know do uh Kashmir yeah they were
incredible yeah play Kashmir original
Kashmir and just take a look at and and
then Jimmy Page I mean John Baum before
he died those newer one ya know you want
to get the young one yeah do that
he was live with steady [ __ ] sick ah
I feel like that's such a better touch
John Bonner oh yeah look at these guys
they were giants and he would wear the
shirt of the woman he had sex with the
night before yes so he always had a
woman's shirt on watch
[Music]
and look at that look up the lyrics of
this do you think he [ __ ] all the
chicks yes and dude no just girls you
think yes I don't know bro promise I sit
with elders of a gentle race this world
has seldom seen they talk of days for
which they sit and wait and all will be
revealed they were deep [ __ ]
deep speaking a deep yo Flynn ballsed
even that big titty girl yep they were
probably the most influential they were
the most influential group for bands
like everybody from Motley Crue to
everybody had long blonde hair and they
had high voices let's say what's in tune
that freddie mercury biopic the Bohemian
Rhapsody the the band because they blew
the [ __ ] up right and they were together
forever and they're like having
arguments and Freddie wants to go do his
own thing which is not how it happened
in real life they all want to do their
own thing break up and they got this big
offer and the band member says the the
wisest thing and they've said before he
says dance just don't go away and fail
he was band's breakup that's why yeah
yeah yeah I don't it's not like they
just stopped producing good music cries
they just they break up they can't
really get together anymore
yeah well was that plan it was when John
Bonham died of a he was drinking and he
died on his own throw up he laid down
and he threw up and died that way but he
was the drummer's drummer like and he
was a huge part of the band the huge
part of their sound I've had drums he
ain't it's a team I've had drummers
explain what he does and it's so subtle
and hard to to emulate but Freddie
Mercury says when so when they all went
to go solo which started with the
drummer go on do his own thing Freddie
Mercury got offered four million dollars
do his own thing which back tens I round
like twelve fourteen million dollars he
went off and he you they said go here
we'll give you the best sound guys in
the world from guitar bass drums and he
goes I had the very best thought and
listen to everything I did he was in it
doesn't work now tells the band he goes
because I didn't get any pushback from
him yeah this guy didn't make fun of me
for this lurk this guy didn't tell me
this would be better you know so it
doesn't work Wow
he was they gave me everything I wanted
but it doesn't work
there's a really really good and
interesting point so in in whenever you
do a play whenever you do a movie I've
had a lot of people who are very
successful at this tell me this you will
always get a better product when the
writer comes with his vision the
director comes with a contrary vision
the actors come from with their vision
and everybody's kind of clashing it's a
soup it's a soup and then you fight and
you compromise you you kind of know this
what I want to do try this and when you
all have a different point of view a lot
of times that's when magic happens
what's this and also your writing with
podcasting to so many people I love
meetings with people in there you go
dude we're gonna put this guy in this
guy others for me the biggest podcast
erica's this guy is this many followers
yeah this guy has this many polish he
thinks this that this guy thinks is I
are they friends
here's no idea do they know each other
he's not gonna sign Awards it doesn't
work like oh we're gonna take a previous
fighter and kameen and put them together
it's firing the kid doesn't work like
that doesn't work does not work like you
just can't know he doesn't
it's a weird chemistry that you can I
replace Brian and you have a bigger show
yeah what stuff no that's not what hey
hold on hold on maybe at firm might have
black lung I'm gonna have black lung
cousin Sacramento oh we got to talk
about this here it looked like World War
Z in that day why because it was rated
the worst air in the number one number
one it was were rated the worst air in
the world number one where you worry
doubt I think China everything know that
the worst it was the consider the worst
air in the world so I know in India
where cities in China India were one and
two yeah and sacrimoni went hold my beer
leapfrog both of them so my my cousins
had to come down to LA they're very old
and they had to stay with us because
they were in San Francisco posted watch
dude he was gonna die
then how about me and Jay are looking
for face masks like the you know the
masks that Asians were at the airport
dude we couldn't find him anywhere have
taken over a sec so it's accurate as
hell though whenever I seem like what
the [ __ ] do they know that I don't well
that Wow joke's on me because they all
had them and they were sold out
I tried post mates in them I would you'd
bring one with bedazzles on I don't give
a [ __ ]
you don't want raisi right there oh
that's from my hotel room at 12 in the
afternoon Utz
it got worse in the morning at
night that night do you I mean you just
want to stay indoors do that's nuts
also all schools are canceled to the
hazardous colleges elementary schools
middle schools high everything's shut
down this cannot stand
and the guy run punchline great manager
because I can't believe eating canceled
yeah oh I really didn't you know it
didn't cross my mind I know I'm the same
way I was like what
no it's sold out shows I'm not gonna
cancel it cancel so I'm here for a man I
two days I'm gonna kill me
I did not feel good I've never heard Jay
Saab snore louder in my life really oh
my god he has a snoring problem already
I think's cuz it's wait but you took a
nap and we're watching college football
and I uh I will walk on it dude you
gotta stop something's going on there
he's like the smoke he's gotta get now
he's gotta get that can be apnea - he's
got a fight - he has that man for sure
yeah
he's in shape he's just family dude he
got his smile you're just too thick he's
like a bulldog he's a zoo bulbous you
mean a naturally thick guy there
yeah hey how about where to write this
fresh trout for breakfast um we didn't
eat the night before we gotten late
we're starving and this is our first
meal we sit down and I asked the lady I
go what like what should we order not
from here you're everyone told to come
to this restaurant what should we order
just we're known for our chicken and
waffles and biscuits and gravy enjoy
yours I'll take both those I went what
did you say would you listen we're here
we got to try them like but no we don't
we don't that's why we're both thick as
[ __ ] we don't last either although we
did and there's delicious my son has my
daughter has the natural gene that I
have right where a little bit is just
fine like I can eat half a piece of
chalk - I had that my son my son will
eat what you put in front of him like if
it's a giant piece of cake he'll stuff
at all in his mouth my son's the same
it's nuts I'm the same with like yeah
last night I was good all day well I got
home I want to get the Black Lung out so
I rode the bike for an hour burned a
thousand calories Denis fasted to two
o'clock after my workout and I'm like
all right I have a nice shake for lunch
I'm like you know I'm gonna do no car
from getting shaped my supposed to come
out with me shred
cities can be great I have some nice
steak filet cook that again no carbs
just salted meat and then around 9
o'clock like I got a sweet tooth mmm
about five minutes later I'm like I get
sweet teeth so I'm going to need to go
to the salt & straw and they're in the
freezer and just try it out you got it
no we got a couple scoops that's all
dude I think I'm just take one scoop
I'll be good yeah I see no I'm watching
[ __ ] Bill Clinton get balls deep and
girls and I'm halfway through this
[ __ ] tub yeah and then next I know
part one ends part two strikes up I
can't not not eat the rest of it not and
watch Bill wise ass off so I finished it
you got to eat it all there's a woman I
woke up sworn burned it off I think yeah
and the sweat from this sauna we're in
right now is also helping I I get in an
elevator in a housing complex woman has
get on with a tub of haagen-dazs Swiss
almond chocolate haagen-dazs yeah this
was something to get the [ __ ] out of my
face and and she goes and I'm looking at
and she's in her pajamas and she just
looks at me and I look at her and I go
she goes no no he said no she was that
no but she would have a laugh it all of
me in her mouth but she was not small
gal and she goes she looks at me and she
goes I'm gonna eat it all no I go that's
the condo I literally go and that's the
kind of attitude I'm looking for but she
said it so great Otis said I don't doubt
that girl I know I'm an eater all as
I've said no [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] you me
both it was [ __ ] great need at all
yeah yeah so can do that Sasso will get
on the town what it is man that's
welcome on Taryn he'll eat all the
pickles oh dude you would laugh at this
well at the top right you see this is
now to the stores is real big that is
inspiring others more hot
has certainly entered his share of
problems crispy bacon was born without
[Laughter]
you have to read this story makes me
last so [ __ ] hard when be like they
definitely up iron so many people dear
me like not he's from my hometown he
still kill and you're putting [ __ ]
wheels on crispy bacon crispy picky or
something's gonna have to read this they
can't do that
alright so funny oh dude I was in Japan
I think it was Wednesday or Thursday
night and Shin sent me he released you
know ass talking about those X volts
dude I could not stop laughing
it was totally laughing engine polite
people look at me I call them howitzers
I love that [ __ ] when you just start
laughing so hard it's just so much fun
glad it was hilarious dude that kind of
laughter when you can't stop laughing
nothing better that guy came in with a
wig and we had that meeting long time
years ago me and Brian we're we're not
saying this big deal with a sponsor
won't say the name of big deal is a
supplement company and we drive into
their offices and we're sitting down or
talking they're like Oh Gregor be and
you just run a few minutes behind and
we're like in the middle of me and Brian
are talking like trying to convey
handsome sound why they should sign with
us and this guy comes in muscular big
good-looking look to pay off Brendan
goes that's a seven oh here's a to eat
watching us hi fellas doing they comes
in with this toupee it looked like a
Pittsburgh Steelers helmet and I go
just out of natural [ __ ] iscope hello
get a set of here on yeah right nice and
I go I go it's a wig that's a wig this
way he 1306 week it's a week either I go
oh and he sits down he's dead serious
with the worst wig of all time we were
[ __ ] where I was he lost again
I couldn't stop laughing I could not am
writing as he's stupid all these years
in our eyes and the guy goes outside do
we miss something I'm like I want to be
like yeah you're [ __ ] to baby come on
dude you can't walk in with a helmet
like that it was so like the Pittsburgh
steel door I was like that's he's a
good-looking guy - like a handsome nice
guy but don't wear that you don't need
he thought he was so cool anybody we
only know you're wearing a vest so cool
oh my god I couldn't believe it
oh oh my god I'm is that's top three
funniest moments of my life I was in
tears laughing everyone goes everyone no
one else is laughing just Brian I
remember like my managers with us
yeah like psych guys please and I like
we couldn't stop I couldn't stop you
know we tried shoving food in our mouths
to stop in front of people they make it
I'm slitting him out I have never left
so on the promise that you when you
start laughing and the fucked-up thing
about Brendan is that if something is if
something is you're not supposed to
laugh at like if something's kind of
tragic even it's not his fault but he
has this weird thing where he's like
well they're all killed
like what he's like yeah and and I then
that's when I start laughing we sat down
with a guy who was having trouble and
that's almost said he was having trouble
and Brandon sat down and I knew he was
gonna start to laugh and I looked up
Brian like give me a heads up though I
know
like I'm there to me Brian I get there
and they're just jumping they're
struggling and ice went oh wow yeah and
Brian goes be nice with these six things
be cool yeah oh I think yeah yeah cuz he
had had he had been he'd lived an
unclean life and he had a kind of a his
face was yeah oh yeah
kind of a stroke but it'll give me a
heads up when somebody's faces you know
if you're like hey hey leave me at this
bar but just make sure the guy I'm with
his face is falling on ya cuz I can't
like just took me by simple and I knew I
was gonna text you and and but I just
couldn't and we didn't know him so it
didn't it was fine but I just knew you
were gonna not be able to and it was
that a cruelty it was it was just the
fact that the situation in me that I
haven't a situation is funny to me
that's all it's not you and I ever
laughing at somebody no the problem is
is anything that you're not when you say
something's forbidden you're [ __ ]
you're not allowed to [ __ ] that person
preacher's daughter you can't [ __ ] don't
laugh [ __ ] ever so hey make sure you
don't laugh at this well don't tell me
that cuz now I'm gonna think don't laugh
that's exactly right and then I'm done
if it's really for like Church my buddy
go to church and I just start [ __ ]
laughing I couldn't do Church I've you
just started laughing I'm fart wow dude
three I'm far too mean J were laughing
hard we watch this video of the top like
world dart thrower like in England I
apparently the guy who lost went yeah I
lost he did the dirty sum of all time he
ripped the worst part of my life before
I got up there because I was I was so
unfocused
then their interview and the champ like
he says you ripped fr Dios I never ever
fart it was him it was Sam he does it
smell like boiled eggs up there here's
the whole place was [ __ ] up here's it
wasn't mean though yeah and then he goes
if I worked afar like that [ __ ] my pants
I'd be honest with you guys I would have
[ __ ] my pants wouldn't be able to play
they say Donald Trump does that to
people when you talk to him when he's
negotiating and it's a group of people
and you come over and yes so the guy the
guys say well if you look at these
graphs cuz there you go she ating you're
looking at he's whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
whoa bro your breath is your breath is
horrible Trump that's horrible and your
big guys I go would be the last thing
you expect - no okay through the breath
yeah he does that to be able he's he's
the worst I heard I heard also that he
when he wants he'll he'll know a guy
and he'll he wants to have sex with her
what the wife he'll have the wife in the
office and he'll call the guy on
speakerphone say hey you ready to have
some fun tonight with the ladies and the
guy who talked about Dana why don't
don't jump down Trump
oh sorry oh god oh I'm sorry oh wow no
that's all we got him there that's
French dude Jesus pregnant drop a bomb
there I didn't know that was the case
all right just kidding you got some yeah
well there is areas that he's not very
pleasant looking humanity's I can't top
you just [ __ ] away he looks like a
mean man he really does we don't want to
be friends with him apparently he's he's
the guy you would be friends with you
just don't want to miss your president
because apparently he's funny and silly
and all that but funny can it be with
his upbringing look at those eyebrows
what else you got Jen Wow Eirene current
event what did you come to eat the
president would it kill him to trim his
eyebrows that's the one for sure but
listen if you have a hair problem and
you're like in the present United States
and he can't figure out your [ __ ] bro
like if he can't figure it out you're so
[ __ ]
here's your thing those nut sacs under
his eyes you can fix that it's that that
mohit issue you can have surgery on that
[ __ ] and why is he orange does he put
makeup on that's it's bronzer on his
face he wears bronzer yep it just he
just doesn't put on his doesn't think
bother to put it on it's like if you're
gonna be that vain you'd think the you
know today's makeup artist with you 24/7
to help with your shitty faith correct
because there are some great makeup
artists great who could be like dude we
can get rid of all the vacant should i
do i fit won't we trim up the eyebrows
you're here you know he just doesn't
give a [ __ ]
Berlusconi from Italy he had a hair
transplant and plastic surgery look him
up he was that than a president Friday
eight years I don't think you can do
this a lot like Trump do people lose
Americans don't want they don't want
their president it'll be good-looking
naturally like JFK Bill Clinton back in
the day plastic surgery for men still an
American culture is really looked at I
found upon it yes very like like I had a
guy say I should do my eyes my eyes are
droopy nose not lying
yeah I'd be bad yeah literally would
definitely give you money I don't then
I'm gonna show up like this what's his
name young Baron Scully
no Berlusconi better why I've heard you
they want to do surgery on my ears yeah
that that botched Shawn he wanted to do
surgery on my ears on mechanic just I
can't imagine going under anaesthesia
yeah show him up with the plastic
surgery you look great Berlusconi hair
transplant look at his face like his
teeth don't don't you know what the only
thing I'll do is my teeth he loves like
a [ __ ] stick man look at that
he looks like a wax figure that [ __ ] is
terrible no I don't trust it so much
right politicians look like that dude
look at his hair it's perfectly he got a
hand up man and he sees it bees into
orgies you don't know that
Berlusconi never heard of them Oh
president of Italy for a long dill or no
a huge tycoon huge media tycoon which I
believe in then that became get that
extra tooth what is that doesn't veneers
or veneers but they're brackets they
pregnant
make his teeth look great yeah he's got
fake teeth he's an old man but he made
me billions as a tycoon and then became
the president and just had just had sex
with all the girls literally was
literally was to have an orgy being
presents weird especially when you're
Jesus Christ now when you're a
billionaire tycoon being president it
doesn't seem like the move like even
Howard Stern talks about Donald Trump
needs to be closed you know yes come on
the short time he goes dude it makes
zero sense you're moving in a shittier
house you're gonna ridicule like you
have all you have all the money in the
world being a president you don't want
to do it's not about that it's about
being power it's about power and also
being seen thank you you will you the
most powerful man in the world it's an
ego thing look at that son of a [ __ ]
look at that horrible man goddamn reason
I was looking awful vanity is an ugly
thing as you get older it really is you
wouldn't be saying that if you're ugly
bright yeah like you're a good-looking
dude so do you it doesn't make sense but
you're real I mean what I pay for you to
have surgery yes where are your eyes
what no they're not too bad dude
especially have 52:51 don't say 50
tuition don't
I say 51 I guess Jay was at lunch with
my mom the other day and they're talking
about how he's what's the name who's the
black guy when GQ Man of the Year sex
man yeah EGS Alba yeah they were saying
my mom married jegos I think it was his
wife I got he goes yeah II drew salba
one six three of the year my mom goes
how was he even though you're 50 some
mom goes oh he's not better looking than
Brian I love you yes he is just dreamy I
love your mom
pipe down mom that is so awesome pipe
down it's not on her mom's attracted to
me and she she is and I appreciate that
how does that make you feel let me ask
here uncomforta are you better looking
at him absolutely not well he's gotta
you seen his body he's six for 230 it's
all muscle let's just like a [ __ ] let's
just get rid of the faith let's just get
rid of the body face twice those are
veneers huh I think that's the move guys
I think this - next investment well you
could do something with your teeth how
much are those veneers about two grand a
tooth what's yes - granite - for Celyn
teeth are not cheap mmm how about you
boy dentists out I know some people
don't like they don't have teeth like
cuz I'm like yeah I think you had the
money to get your teeth done I know it's
pretty cheap well I shouldn't say that I
mean he's a lot of money for people you
know who I know but I'm saying if you
have terrible teeth and like you're in
Hollywood I'm like dude once you get
that [ __ ] fit yeah and they can do some
wonders they can were oh my god for some
people that's terrible
look it I think Hilary Duff is so hot
she's a Tom also when the
hardest-working people I've ever seen
really oh my god in the gym she is a
monster she's most badass chick FC in
the gym she's so her Whitney Cummings
when he's a little monster - but Hilary
Duff is a beast in there Wow we're sure
can't say oh damn daddy who was busted
let's go in some Christian may be flawed
I love Megan Fox she's a great person
I know Megan Megan is [ __ ] smart you
want to talk about an actress who's
smart that's a smart woman look at Tom
Cruise
of a guy yeah we saw that one before
Tina that's pretty crazy I don't think
those were his real teeth I think he was
his teeth are very very lopsided anyway
they're not really they're kind of out
over to the side yeah it's like [ __ ] on
the left there all right Kurt events yep
why not why not all right KITT so just
an update on the homeless vet GoFundMe a
story
all three were found guilty actually I
think they found evidence they weren't
prosecuted yet that this was all a scam
you hear about this price yeah and the
girl came out a couple days ago her
lawyers are saying that she didn't know
anything about it and that the homeless
vet and that her boyfriend were the ones
who created the scam and she was just
upon Jesus and the $400,000 and what you
know how they got busted you know how
they get caught they the homeless they
gave the guy who the homeless guy 75
grand he's like where's the rest of my
money
like [ __ ] off he hired a lawyer to come
after them and they're like hold up
what's going on here that cause of these
red flags and they caught him so dummy
dummy who was already there all weighing
on it together then the dummy bomb went
I'll let me hire who knows who drew a
bump let me hire this [ __ ] lawyer to
come after them Wow you're an idiot so
did all of them are in trouble a bit
they're gonna present something yeah if
they're prosecuted they can face should
do at least ten years prison and what
type of prison you know but I really
need to be put away for ten years now
there's scumbags and we should find the
[ __ ] out of them but prison behind bars
are they a threat to society
no GoFundMe is a really beautiful thing
for people and if you're easy and if
it's fun yeah people are gonna scam
maybe making an example of people is I
hate setting somebody away for that long
I think it's a little [ __ ] up unless
like ten years should be reserved ten
life that should be reserved for
[ __ ] guys to murder people get
sick shams yeah
personal endeavor yes we answer so have
you guys seen this clip yet uh yeah okay
well he got banned yeah watch the clip
first is this high school no college
[ __ ] so you see it again you do great
apologies why'd he do it he says that he
was just frustrated his team was losing
I think at that point the game it was 76
to 64 he got frustrated and clocked the
guy oh he got suspended indefinitely
from the University as well as the team
I think that's appropriate yeah you
can't have that and that's that he's a
team you're an ass whatever think of
that now you're [ __ ] [ __ ] you can't
have that yeah you know you know my
stuff like that guys where is he playing
at Pittsburgh state doesn't matter if
there's no prayer after this it doesn't
matter yeah yeah I mean that's a vicious
that's terrible that's [ __ ] awful
it's also Fitchburg State so relax I
thought the end of the world you lose a
game yep exactly Kentucky Duke right
what else get so former Cowboys
linebacker it came out as gay and he's I
think he just got married on Sunday do
you know what he looks like also wins
last when did he retire any long time
he's right the started with the it with
the mid-80s with the Cowboys all right
yeah it's a while ago he's 59 years old
damn good for him man that's tough to
come out that long took a long time and
what if there's any I'm sure there's
some right now
they still don't feel safe to come out
remember that player Sam
I forget his name from Missouri marry
that guy you ready to kiss his boyfriend
at the driver hair he's not playing
anymore no no he's not I caught me by
surprise I don't listen I I don't give a
[ __ ] who you whose dick you sir I don't
care about any of that when I was
watching the draft though
he got announced that he you got draft
like oh that's cool and he's like yeah
then leaned over to this little white
twink and was like oh that's good I was
like oh [ __ ]
all right not that I care but it caught
me wasn't he like a top draft pick I
wasn't here now no um and people like
sillies gay no yeah you want to see a
fella really didn't work out there so he
got drafted though right and so he
kissed him I mean he's just like Oh
leave the little twink
I like how you know the term twink oh
yeah you know the term otter they're
like that up girl who's drafted in the
sea I'm watching this at home in my
underwear like god that's a cool story
man so Michael Sam yeah that's fantastic
got the seventh round my god this is
cool man good for him first gay dude
ever drafted right on bro right on so
cool in it God fantastic he's crying a
little hard though yeah yeah no he's
emotional man
yeah let me get his boyfriend boyfriend
boyfriend for Mizzou boyfriend it's
skinny that's a good-looking big man I
wonder whose novels bottom though that's
a beautiful man isn't he we stopped
who's bottom but he's crying for a long
time now is the outside linebacker who's
all-sec the top you think or is he the
power bottom look I just rubbing
rubbing that bicep bro just happened to
be there that's not tween school boy we
got just caught me by surprise that's
all I thought that was his agent I'd no
idea yeah well good for him
yeah but he did what's he doing now
right
I don't he was in the CFL that bums me
out because he was so happy to have made
it and then I'll brothers you owe me
guys like that just because he's gay
feel bad for him no there's so many guys
like that you just don't make it it's
just it's the pros is a different
[ __ ] thing doesn't work if it's the
professional football dude yeah oh he's
on Dancing with the Stars in 2015 so
what do you do now the last name does a
spoke at a LGBTQ advocacy group in
Missouri State Capitol
scroll up with football what's the last
thing you died there yo Montreal and
that was in two and 15 retirement August
2015 sound ants on Twitter stepping away
from professional football due to mental
health reasons
clearly shows experience as an author
and motivational speaker there you go
well yeah I guess it must have been I
guess in the locker room if you listen
if he was really good it was your honor
if he was [ __ ] [ __ ] right dude a fuse
Aaron Rodgers no one gives a flying [ __ ]
I gotta be on yeah he's winning game
where Jesus went around a 40 in a 499
that's not good he was up that gift in
six - yeah you know it's I like you some
Lawrence Taylor right now SEC defense
play the year off he has a nose for the
game like an AK that's a big deal right
what does that mean SEC it's you know
some there's my argument to this if your
balls even college football some think
this he sees the best conference you
know that's huge then so he was a really
good player he was a bad days in college
football pocket and these amazing which
always doesn't always transfer is he
still with his man now was he live back
right he's that we said he was a
linebacker la en okay for six - as a
Deanna short though isn't it guys you
can do it yeah is he still with his
mouth these pictures here I don't know
we Brian
broke up I think with a nice young
blonde he's a dime piece so you know
that there are other guys are probably I
bet he's not [ __ ] you know I mean he's
the toast of the town
oh that is boy I don't know out 100
hashtag ice hazard Botox on the left
there huh it's not bad-looking dude huh
not the get in the laughs Sam Sam's a
good-looking man there you go right
there there you go right there where
right there in the middle didn't they
build it
hey about that dude sexy ass mother what
I kiss him in his mouth oh and I throw
the boy must have broke up no they broke
up dude yeah oh well Brian with their
separate ways
oh there's another maybe his man was
like you know of frickin groupie Joe mob
my bro
oh my boo they look happy good-looking
kids man good-looking fellas you did you
see Will Smith's son which one I mean uh
you know the will Hayden Oh Jaden wears
skirts oh but did you see what he did on
stage do you know Tyler the Creator is
the famous rapper he on stage he goes I
want it I don't know what my thing is I
won't anyone know Tyler creators my
boyfriend he's been my boyfriend for
years he's gay do you know that it makes
sense he's gay there you go and I guess
Tyler crater came out and said he's bi
likes white boys he writes about ends
music he raps about being gay Wow
well that's why I'm called the F word
you know cuz it's like he says tell her
Tyler does wanna me say this but Tyler's
my [ __ ] boyfriend he's been my
[ __ ] boyfriend my whole [ __ ]
life what which is weird cuz he's a he's
pretty young yeah Jaden can that booty
hole beat in for quite some time sounds
like I mean manager easygoing no doubt
nope because they're both they both like
there was a dick taste and I mean if
they are who cares
yeah I would always see him at in
Calabasas and he was you're here Will
Smith talk about him
no yes Matias we [ __ ] up there yeah we
[ __ ] up no yeah you're making a joke
Oh like what he threw out spear ding
he's sound legacy what Jay we [ __ ] up
a little bit yeah we [ __ ] up there
that's hilarious
yeah yeah I see him he has these friends
he's just a kid who grew up like a
little prince so it's hard to making
music in the sells itself
mmm wears dresses Tyler craters actually
a really creative dude he's also the
voice of the new Grinch movie very can
vacuum is he yeah no I'm listening I'm
sure I mean like if someone's like dude
you believe those two her [ __ ] I look
at that picture
yeah no [ __ ] yeah right yeah no she's a
beautiful Ethiopian woman right there
I'm sorry to say that but he's a
beautiful Ethiopian woman yeah I mean I
just he looked identical to his mother
he's a beautiful I mean you know that
the mouth the skin the delicate features
you know anywheres he wears simple wear
dress yeah he's been known to wear
dresses probably create I didn't know
that I found out this weekend that is by
I had no idea I don't know who Tyler
creative is Tyler Tyler the Creator okay
I don't know who that is
it's okay he's a he's an actor rapper
but he also he's the voice from the new
Grinch movie gotcha
very talented he's the voice of the
Grinch of the Grinch is an arat I'm
sorry he's the narrator for the game Oh
Pharrell is a narrator who is the voice
of the Grinch uh it's Cumberbatch or
whatever yeah I better get Benedict
comes back yeah yeah Tyler crater just
sings the music for me how that movie do
my kids sing well just so-so on it it
might just off this thing you're
thinking for Rob maybe oh you're right I
like fur looks like you looks like they
don't wait dear we go to the crater
you're made a song rich there you go
there you go play that top left hit it
do you think not my thing my my three
now whole Ryder creative group song and
suck your dick which is news to meet
news to me
news to me what else you got grant so a
man was arrested for multiple drug
charges and his mugshot went viral he's
a real MVP cat have you seen this much
Brian oh my god I tell you I need to get
in the gym to get your neck like this
you are gonna be so [ __ ] jealous of
this guy's net find a thicker neck I
[ __ ] challenge you do it do it okay
show Brian this guy's goddamn neck oh my
god
well that's deformed yeah it's just kind
of sad no that's Jim bro he's in the gym
well I don't think so but that's
impressive
it's a crazy I mean just making the
worst dude those comments are hilarity
done sticking my neck out for I'm
grateful look at the side thank you neck
it's crazy snake I've ever seen is he
really strong Spike's way of spikes this
guy he's next bigger than this girl we
sure are we sure that's a deformity or
is he just in the gym [ __ ] do high
neck work let's see to care of spikes
oh okay of spikes no hon just leave it
here first and we've seen tequila just a
football player I go back and I read
that which one's hot yeah the thing he
has some sort of issue it's got a it's
gotta be some sort of different I can't
just be swole bro geez um he or he uh it
says he responds here
so this is where I'll get sad though if
you responds and it's oh there is no
sound every feet we had it gave me a
change baby I'm trying to [ __ ] it up
like the first time I ever coming on
some [ __ ] that new head is just so many
I can't fade all y'all severe
weird table taking - he seems norm
he's just Jack just Jack who's like
looks like an athlete yeah well alright
I don't always say what's it say man I'm
with wide neck somebody shot went viral
is out of jail so he got out man you got
out free Charles Deon McDowell hey roll
up this girl up it says read some of
these comments it says you people should
be ashamed of yourself - all this
negativity hey hey put her in jail and
throw away the key dude up those neck -
charges his neck is still at large what
they charge this guy with necklace my
neck my back they took my meth in my
chest that boy can drink peanut butter
[Laughter]
where our shoulders right
that boy could write peanut butter some
of those popular memes yeah
holy Oh oh my god from Mario
I don't know that character from King
Koopa King Koopa poor guy tennis Odell
Beckham jr. yeah hey buddy he's he
doesn't seem to have a mental now issue
or a snack people born giant net all
right
good one cat that's [ __ ] what else
you drive me laugh hard see the boy look
like you should drink peanut butter oh
[ __ ] on a month this beast Nick I've
ever seen okay did you hear about this
ESPN report from a senior writer Jeff
Condoleezza Rice the national security
adviser about football though so all I
use here this first this is very
interesting because this past week the
Browns general manager John Dorsey came
out and said he would consider anybody
for the job including women and as it
turns out there is one woman that the
Browns have on their wish list to go
speak to and that would be the former
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
who's a high school Browns fan now the
Browns were interested in getting her
ideas and her input into the
organization she was with the team out
in Oakley she could become the first
woman ever to interview for an NFL head
coaching job and it comes it I the
Tiffany said wouldn't make English [ __ ]
no X's and O's that's the craziest [ __ ]
because she's a good leader knows she
structure of business she said she's a
Rhodes Scholar she's a concert pianist
but she doesn't she's not qualified to
be a coach with Balkan it's not a woman
or man thing but it if you put it no but
no it's not but if you put you on musk
is the head coach correct because he's
so smart you put him in there cuz he
knows how to figure things out DUI can
get the respect from the players no I
think this is a joke cuz look at what
she said no it's not I love my balance
and the state news they will hire an
experienced coach to take her to the
next level on a more serious note I do
hope the NFL will start to bring women
into the coaching profession as position
coaches and eventually coordinators and
head coaches but they'd have to play the
game another game of course one doesn't
have to play the game to understand it
and motivate players sparsely
it's time to develop a pool of
experienced women coaches I think the
Browns was trying to get good PR why is
it time to sew a line but why is it time
to put great women coach is why explain
why it makes it doesn't--it equal not
wimp there what the hell God where do I
even start with that what's this so this
is bar so there than what the reporter
at first that they were looking for a
head coach and looking possibly for
Condoleezza Rice then they reported this
afterwards that the Cleveland Browns
responded to it oh he says rice has not
been discussed yeah no she don't know
the jr. there is on all these people to
to have women like conductors even
though they're very few have women
composers even though all the great
geniuses were men there's so much
pressure on the [ __ ] they were looking
for a trans conductor because they had
to they there's so much pressure for
diversity for the sake of diversity and
over competence over anything else it's
just become madness and it all started
in the [ __ ] academic circles these
[ __ ] academics who don't live in the
real world like if you're qualified for
the job then you get the job that's how
I look at it individual I don't give a
[ __ ] whether you're gay or whatever but
women coaches ok why this is there is
there is not real they don't know the
game but that the ESPN head writer
reported it it's really some shefter is
that there is meetings it's good for it
but they better but so UCLA now has a
diversity Dean and what that means is
that the diversity Dean has to make sure
that there are more women teaching and
in the engineering department right
school right and and it has nothing to a
qualification it's exactly like this
bill that Jerry Brown the [ __ ] [ __ ]
brought to the floor with with a lot of
liberal senators who said that
California companies have to have women
on their board they have to it's
mandated I don't think it's gonna pass
the Supreme Court but it's mandated it's
it's Marxism it's [ __ ] like equality
of outcome not equality of opportunity
and so the only delineation is what you
got to have we have we have to have more
ovaries instead of gonads go down a
weird Road man but this is what we're
dealing with
there's only get also Adam Schefter do
bad
don't report that [ __ ] what else you
got alright this um 17 year old driver
f3 or Formula three did you see this
crash at all no this is Macau I missed
this this is the craziest crash I've
ever seen amber so she did break her
spine fracture spine but she survived
and she's okay no no nothing to do with
the paralyzation yet so check this out
[Music]
boom holy rock weights I see it in full
speed Jude she flew over I got so many
different angles to she clipped someone
ahead of her wet-eared yeah I lost
control
well your bud on them so I show
different [ __ ]
these cars are so goddamn fast
dammit you only survived
I'll show you this angle
oh how crazy is that
dude those people are lucky they didn't
get hit everyone's lucky here so she
didn't die no she even responded on
Twitter saying she's okay she has a
fractured spine though plan a discussion
huh right absolutely holy [ __ ] man so
she has a fractured spine how'd she get
that much air look at when you see it
from different angles yeah she's going
oh they're going so fast
just a slight how fast did you see it it
just went
life goes on Oh
how fast is that [ __ ]
that's so weird I don't know how she got
airborne she must have hit that other
car yeah in front of her Oh cuz yeah she
must get a little and sweat like a ramp
so so what's wrong with it if she'll be
able to race again she's not paralyzed
she's not paralyzed as far as we know
right now she responded on Twitter but
she has a fractured spine yeah 17 years
old - she got it out of a piledriver
that's rough on the spot it's base but
best case scenario that's her yeah no
she's actually really pretty
Sophia floor yeah Wow gorgeous that's
her yeah that's cool man she's what else
you got um this guy Cody Mackenzie do
you guys remember him yes he had a
Mackenzie teen that he was really
well-known for he had a what the
Mackenzie teen he did a guillotine that
only he did right he got like a ton ago
yeah he was on The Ultimate Fighter yeah
yeah so he's accusing a Nevada state
commission that wanted to get his pee
tests urine tests of sexual harassment
he's a different bird man
very very different he was in Alaska
like doing yeah she's one of those guys
so he's saying that well first of all he
didn't want to pee in the cup and then
he actually ended up submitting a fake
urine sample but prior to this he said
the Commission guy came out and took his
dick out he goes it's not that hard he
started wiggling it in front of him that
probably never happened all right I
didn't I think he's trying to back up
the Commission hold it I waited did he
find out
he finds out I write or 70 I think 45 35
or 45 no yeah he fired up that was the
name at 45 not a 35 ER who's checking
our favors you our favors teammate the
dude that he just came back he's killing
it Chad Mendes yes I think if our Chad
Mendes so at 45
yeah I mean he isn't Chad Mendes me too
no I just had to tell
that's a 180 he found out 145 well I
could be making finds my money no just
gotta you know the right thing to scroll
down you're out the right thing wasn't
cuz though Wikipedia have his record on
there dude Nami is wait he says 180 yeah
go to world now that means he walks
around 180 go to his mixed martial arts
grab the UFC career right there it
should have his record if he keeps going
down all you mean is record yeah um so
let's see but in the UFC he fought guys
fight all over
Sam stout Linda Garcia that's 45 10
minutes 45 so he's flat out 55 Leonard
55 you know Chad Mendes he fought at 45
so 45 and 55 but all the way up to 180 a
lot of fights look anyway guillotine do
you won by though a shitload yeah yeah
definitely get sexual harass those must
be real what else you got min this guy
he was arrested because he he said he
was gonna drop a bomb and they actually
thought it was a terrorist thing when he
was talking about taking a [ __ ] at a
chicken restaurant wait who did he saves
gonna huge staff I'm sure I'm gonna drop
bombs in here I'm gonna drop a bomb in
the bathroom I mean the staff is so dumb
to report him on this no but I guess the
family there's a chance that he really
did say that he wanted to bomb yeah we
know what that means I'm about but says
employs no police said y'all bout to
close right now because I'm going to get
a bomb that's what employers say and
blow this place know get a bomb that
stuff he said yeah I guess is he
probably said I'm gonna blow up the
bathroom and by the way didn't have any
bombs so what's not you know when the
cops tracked down Posey claimed it was a
giant mr. stern I explained he told
staffers he's going to blow the bathroom
up meaning he was gonna poop his brains
out cops didn't buy what Posey was
selling rest he's accused of facing two
counts of community came false
information of planned arson give me a
[ __ ] break
he was gonna poop his brains huh that
close that you gotta close this place
down I'm gonna take a [ __ ] I've said
that I've said that I've never said that
exact thing I should've the staff took a
state ID hey everyone shut down he's
gonna drop bomb well he might have been
just a [ __ ] you know being silly and
funny but you know he's not a terrorist
and does he have bombs uh yeah that's it
don't think he needs to go to prison no
it's not arrest him I got other things
to worry
yeah a man took a [ __ ] what else you got
this was not a big deal but former New
York Mayor Bloomberg donated 1.8 billion
dollars to John Hopkins University yes
so that if kids don't have to pay back
those crazy loans yeah that's just it's
straight-up yeah [ __ ] sakes you and what
do you Billy how much money does he is
gonna be Freemont Michael Bloomberg [ __ ]
he owns Bloomberg News he's one point
eight billion Oh to boost financial aid
for low and middle income students
that's really that's an incredible
school um there needs to be more of that
and how much does giving a financial aid
76 look up his net worth dude I think
it's like something like 50 billion oh
wow so 1.88 ship for him oh really
holy [ __ ] that Mike Bloomberg did a
great job in New York as the mayor it's
a lot of my nominal job yeah good for
him little fella what else you got
that's pretty much it well Brendan man
it's hot in here dude yeah it's hot in
here man honestly it's a little hot
well dude it's Thanksgiving weekend cat
what are you doing for Thanksgiving I'm
picking up my sister on Wednesday
gobble these nuts gobble-gobble minutes
thank you I said yes okay
she's coming though she's coming into
down tables in the dick though yeah what
well no I've seen diskettes sister want
some pumpkin pie I said a lot what
no you said she's here for a family sir
that's right I feel like you're turning
this into a sexual event she's here the
turkey
I'll try to help them out here to get
the turkey and have mashed potatoes
cooking Kat I think we all get out and
we're men what what you can cook Kat
yeah yeah she can cook to look at what
are you guys gonna have to be like a fat
kid so about that like chunky enough you
have pictures huh no I do not carry
pictures from when I was when she was
chin does a marshmallow chin does Jenny
screech 300 pounds I don't think I was
actually that big but in comparison to
like my cousins like a lot of Asian
girls are like skinny fat like really
good metabolisms what we need touch them
they like sink in sure Susan Sharon your
sister stays in shape yes yes she does
mmm teacher I do a little personal
training on the side it's funny mention
that I also do personals you have a
fight now we both do we work as we do at
one to come she wants to again find the
kid workshop it was a great place in
yeah right cross the street and Playa
Vista and I'm partly off to Alvarado
yeah provide pokeballs ain't ours
give me another set of that I'll bring
some cobra blood after this you owe you
that little girl there okay you're super
cute Missy
super cute what I'm just choking you out
there [ __ ] you I'm not fat you're just a
little cute girl yeah you do have a neck
like that guy and that's the only thing
that's not now cutie pie
it's super cute yeah all right well good
luck on Thanksgiving guys Oh we'll see
our we're gonna show on Wednesday aren't
we yeah we will see you go are you here
on what stakeout yeah okay
I know if you get ready men is that it
ready that's it buddy all right Randy
next we enjoy your Thanksgiving but
we'll be on Wednesdays this and The Long
Goodbye for the holidays but next week
Friday Saturday em in New York City
Brian I mean you're stomping grounds if
your dad wants tickets dumb I'll give
him a disco why well thank you New York
City Gotham comedy club next Friday
Saturday New York City after that I'm in
New Mexico right outside Albuquerque two
shows December 7th and 8th and then just
announced I will be at the ice house
with friends if you like Johnson County
attache tells me I do all right
I Scouse Brian's gonna be there in
France the ice house that is December
28th through the break up you're gonna
be in Africa then I'll be in South
Africa I'm sorry you're going back or
you know your wife was there yeah now
we're going south
interesting yeah okay well Brian won't
be there's been Africa something ice
house in Pasadena
I'll find other people some 28th 29th
and then the granja go so San Diego
January 19th two shows those are almost
sold out which is crazy
it's a Saturday night in San Diego shoot
my one-hour comedy special special
theater get your tickets now t5k calm we
also got a special announcement because
we're doing our first fine kid Black
Friday mm-hmm so this Friday yeah just
the black is Friday evolved blackest of
all we're restocking some are vintage
shirts babish any Fight Club Scrooge
McDuck oh the one love with Bryan Callen
and Street Fighter tees
different colors some new designs but
they're on the website this Friday for
Black Friday 25% off the entire site
it's so blast blackish it's [ __ ] black
is [ __ ] yeah yeah chief at kake.com for
this Friday's Black Friday we're
restocking all our new old vintage
shirts get them and get to get from my
comedy team at kake.com
that'd be that's a wrap gobble gobble
this is the fine kid route